bonsoir lui si et oui avec un double
anniversaire celui de la renaissance 5 e
siècle bien sûr et puis aussi le 500e
anniversaire de la mort de leonardo la
cie c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes
amboise alors ce que je propose aux
téléspectateurs c'est de faire un petit
peu un cours d'histoire on révise on va
voir ce qu'est le château d'amboise
grâce au reportage de mélanie trash
l'air et stéphane ont l'eau luceau une
silhouette gracieuse au dessus de la
loire
loin du château défensif médiévale à la
renaissance amboise est devenu sont eux
l'époque
l'édifice était cinq fois plus grand
[Musique]
l'évolution du gothique et vers une
expression assez sophistiqué et en fait
c'est surtout la l'utilisation du
château qui a changé et dont lieu d'être
une place forte
le château devient un lieu qui se veut
confortable et prestigieux et donc tous
les éléments de décors vont devenir très
très important une décoration raffinée
reims aux arabesques chérubins motifs
symétriques inspiré souvent de
l'antiquité le style italien dans toute
sa splendeur amboise c'est le château de
prestige par excellence sur lui tenait
angoisse on a et bien françois 1er qui
va être aussi élevé à amboise beaucoup
d'enfants de roi en fait grandissent
dans ce château sur une forteresse ça
c'est vraiment un lieu privilégié pour
l'éducation des enfants et françois 1er
lui finalement par la suite décidera
d'en rajouter lui aussi son empreinte à
ce château est donc rare ajouté au début
de la renaissance le deuxième étage les
mansardes que l'on peut voir ici
amboise détonne avec des fenêtres plus
grand pour plus de lumière mais aussi
cette prouesse architecturale
révolutionnaire c'est tour été
construites comme des portes d'entrée
dans le château sont des portes
sécurisées mais permettant comme dans un
parking moderne par une rampe qui fait
plusieurs boucles de pouvoir accéder
pour des chevaux et des attelages depuis
le niveau de la ville sur les terrasses
du château l'année 418 est marquée par
l'organisation de nombreuses fêtes à la
cour qui sont organisées par léonard de
vinci et notamment de fête au mois de
mai qui ont lieu dans ce château qui
sont des fêtes grandioses et donc on a
une cour qui se veut fastueuse et
décante et qui montre au delà du
souverain le prestige du royaume de
france le 2 mai 1519 le grand génie mort
à françois 1er lui accordera la faveur
d'être inhumé au château
voilà alors bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
le conservateur de ce château dont on
dit dans le reportage est bien que c'est
un endroit absolument charmant et qui
représente aussi la renaissance quelque
chose de brillant quelque chose de on va
dire de de significatif de cette époque
oui c'est vraiment un lieu qui marque
presqu'île et oui et c'est presque
l'identité de ces châteaux de la loire
il se trouve ici dans une illustration
puisque c'est le basculement entre la
période médiévale
oui et puis ces temps modernes que l'on
appelle la renaissance et on a donc un
lieu qui est un lieu de pouvoir mais que
aussi un lieu de résidence
il y est et comme tel c'est un lieu où
va s'écrire donc l'histoire avec le
faste que l'on veut lui donner
oui notamment avec un invité prestigieux
que l'on commémore cette année
évidemment c'est léonard de vinci
d'honneur de vinci et là on se trouve
dans la chapelle petite chapelle du qui
serait juste à côté du château
d'azay-le-rideau et là vous pouvez voir
et bien vous qui étaient les spectateurs
qui est devenu peut-être jamais ici dans
ce château bien voici le ton de leonardo
da vinci's voilà c'est comme ça la
réponse régénère de vinci
en fait cette tombe n'est pas la
première tombe
or et il a été enterré dans la grande
église qui était dans le château cette
église était détruite au début du 19e
siècle et les restes ont été transférés
dans la deuxième moitié du 19e
dans cette petite chapelle est donc
c'est vraiment le lieu qui symbolise le
lien en fait entre le roi et l'artiste
parce que l'artiste a voulu au delà de
la mort rester sous la protection de son
mécène alors absolument et en plus même
s'il ne se voyait pas beaucoup il y
avait une grande complicité entre les
deux oui on dit même s'il est clair que
le roi lorsqu'il parlait de léonard de
vinci ou quand il lui parlait il
l'appelait mon père et donc il y avait
une relation qui était une relation qui
était sans doute
il voulait montrer son estime mais aussi
il y avait une notion d'affection dans
cette relation est vraiment léonard de
vinci à trouver avec françois 1er pour
la dernière étape de sa vie
un protecteur et un protecteur qui s'est
montré généreux très bien merci en tout
cas de nous avoir reçu toute cette
journée dans ce merveilleux château
vous connaissez stéphane bern j'imagine
je connais un peu stéphane bern et je
pense que tout le monde connaît stéphane
bern voilà et c'est un bon avocat du
patrimoine et à bonn avocats du château
d'ailleurs on l'a rencontré et c'est
fabien qui excite un entretien a été
réalisé il ya quelques jours
bonjour c'était flou règne un bon jour
où sommes nous ici nous sommes dans la
salle du conseil du château d'amboise
une salle magique vous voyez veilleurs
on célèbre à la fois de bretagne et roi
de france puisqu'il y aller les hermines
de bretagne et les fleurs de lys des
rois de france c'est tous les rois de
france et 6 2 charles 8 france qui mord
ici en se cognant le front contre un
taux de porte françois 1er c'était le
roi du château d'amboise aussi même si
ensuite il s'est fait construire le
château de chambord
j'ai une tendresse particulière pour ce
château d'amboise d'abord ce qu'il
domine la loire il est aidé majestueux
il est singulier et il est à la fois on
sent là la beauté de la renaissance qui
naissaient relais châteaux ne seront
plus seulement défensif ils deviennent
des châteaux d'agrément vous dites à
propos de la renaissance un monde c'est
un un autre n'est c'est vraiment une
période charnière dans l'histoire de
france
moi je crois que c'est vraiment une
période charnière de notre histoire
d'abord parce que il faut il faut pas
oublier une chose c'est que ça a
sédimenté depuis la publication de la
bible de gutenberg ensuite c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre de savants ont été
chassés de constantinople arrivent en
italie le roi de france françois 1er
fait ces campagnes italiennes
on connaît et ramène tous ces savants et
ces grands esprits en france et donc à
tout d'un coup il ya la réforme
en même temps c'est à dire que l'être
humain l'homme où la femme redevient
revient au coeur de la société
c'est plus seulement le dogme établi
tout d'un coup on met on met en cause
les règles préétablies et chauve scène
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'intéressant on ne reviendra pas en
arrière
on essaiera souvent au cours de
l'histoire mais on ne pourra pas comment
la renaissance est elle arrivée dans
notre région centre val de loire
et bien c'est au fond le centre la
région centre val de loire était là où
vibrer le coeur du roi parce que les
rois de france évidemment en comme nous
aujourd'hui découvre cette douceur de
vivre en val de loire et donc décide de
s'y installer
c'était aussi une manière de gouverner
le pays parce que on est vraiment au
coeur de la france et et s'y installe la
cour est encore nomades penser que ce
château de chambord je crois que de
mémoire françois 1er mai a dormi 42 nuit
s'est relativement peu pour pour un
château mais parce que on a les deux
courts en cours ce que je trouve assez
intéressant et c'est françois 1er avec
voulait faire plaisir à sa mère louise
de savoie et voulait construire une
capitale grandiose à romorantin qui
vraiment le à l'époque le centre de la
france pour pouvoir gouverner tous ses
états
[Musique]
le projet n'aura pas lieu et parce que
l'argent manque et cet argent sera
utilement employés pour construire
chambord et faire aujourd'hui
vous savez quand on parle de célébrer la
renaissance qui est important de dire
c'est que le monde entier nous envie
cette constellation de chefs-d'oeuvre
qui sont réunies le long de ce secours
ligériens qui l'a qui est qui qui la loi
vous pensez que cet anniversaire peut
intéresser le grand public mais bien sûr
cet anniversaire nous concerne tous
d'abord parce que ça nous ramène à nos
racines un peuple qui ne sait pas d'où
il vient ne sait pas où il va tant que
ça nous ramène à nos racines les racines
du de cette renaissance
là au bord de la loire et je pense que
pour tout là tous ceux qui vivent dans
cette région du centre val de loire
peuvent se sentir peuvent s'identifier à
cet anniversaire et en même temps tous
ensemble parce que les célébrations il
ya 500 projets pour 500 ans d'histoire
c'est 500 projets qui vont tout au long
de l'année et bien émaillé le court 2
j'allais dire ddd jours pour pour
montrer et bien cette effervescence
intellectuelle via cinq siècles
c'est peut-être se projeter dans
l'avenir comment est-ce que et bien on
peut aussi innover autant qu'on l'a fait
sous léonard de vinci
quel sera votre rôle exactement précis
mais mon rôle est de vous parler
mon rôle est celui d'un ambassadeur
d'être le type bavard qui peut-être et
pas très compétent pour vous parler de
la renaissance mais en tout cas j'ai je
parle avec sincérité avec mon coeur mon
coeur c'est de dire au fond j'ai la
chance d'habiter dans cette région
j'habite à peu au nord de la région
l'eure-et-loir fait partie de la région
centre val de loire met au nord on a
cathédrale de chartres aussi mais tout
autour dans cette région aussi
département bien il se passe quelque
chose et on doit tous ensemble célébrer
cet anniversaire
je me sens un héritier de 2,2 de léonard
de vinci j'ai envie de créer j'ai envie
d'imaginer le monde
demain j'ai envie d'avoir des projets
fous vous savez qu'il a imaginé des
premiers temps qu'il a imaginé alors des
choses guerrier amène à imaginer des
avions qui volent des montgolfières il a
tout tout tout est sorti de son cerveau
génial et ensuite c'est devenu une sorte
de réalité peut-être tous ensemble on
peut rêver le monde de demain
merci à vous voilà superbe phrase on
c'est ce que dit stéphane bien bonjour
thibault alors vous êtes docteur en
histoire
vous êtes aussi donc chercheur associé
au csr le cnsr c'est le centre d'études
supérieures de la renaissance
alors là on parle à un vraiment un grand
spécialise leurs naissains je tiens à
préciser d'ailleurs que thibault il sera
avec nous dans un documentaire qui sera
diffusé lundi soir sur 160 valoir qu'ils
s'appellent les codes de chambord parce
que vous connaissez bien chambre alors
bien disait qu'il préférait peut-être ce
château ici de d'amboise plutôt que
celui de de chambord vous préférez
chambord j'imagine oui oui oui forcément
chez j'ai une préférence pour chambord
mais ce sont deux châteaux très
différenciant pour ça qu'il n'avait pas
le même usage non plus alors nous sommes
dans la chambre du roi c'est une
reconstitution de la de la chambre du
roy lé relais 107 chambres ou oui et non
non dans la mesure où il ne reste aucun
meuble royal de cette époque tu as tout
le mobilier royal a brûlé fin du siècle
donc on n'a aucun meuble de françois 1er
on est obligé de faire des
reconstitutions d'accord
mais c'est je dirais que c'est une bonne
re des creux constitution c'est tout à
fait dans l'esprit rosita isa l'expert
je voudrais que l'on jette juste à hanoi
avant d'aller découvrir un endroit
secret c est bien cette toile qui est là
qui arrivé il ya peu de temps de
guillaume ménage au en qu'as-tu fait en
1780 qui a été restauré où l'on voit
alors là c'est le fantasme de la de
l'artiste où l'on voit léonard de vinci
avec françois 1er il est en train de
mourir mais c'est à fontainebleau
donc voilà c'est l'histoire de
l'histoire et on continue comme ça
maintenant on va aller voir on va aller
voir un endroit secret ici parce que
s'il ya des secrets à chambord il y
aussi des secrets
il est des endroits cachés à ce choc
dans ce château dans doit être regardée
alors marc mettez nous sommes dans un
endroit ici que l'on va dire qualifié de
secret méconnu en tout cas très beau
très méconnu puisqu'il n'est accessible
qu'à une partie infime de nos visiteurs
ouais c'est sur demande uniquement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la tour cavaliere
alors on connaît la partie haut de la
tour cavaliere là c'est la partie basse
tout cavalière tout simplement parce que
les chevaux est monté les cavaliers
manqué alors les chevaux pas n'importe
lesquels ceux du roi et de l'empereur
déclaré dans le lent très solennelle
justement permettant aux rois
l'accueillir les hôtes de marque
quelle époque alors je crois que comme
c'est gênant euros il ya beaucoup de
graffitis et je réponds de la ffh
tivement on a une date de construction
qui est ici qui se cache ici 498 398
alors on est dans une construction qui
commence à la fin du xvème siècle sur
l'ordre de charles witt qui s'achèvera
pour la 2e tour cavalière au début du
16e siècle sous le règne de louis xii
voilà donc elle va traverser quand même
un certain nombre de deux siècles avant
de voir ce le côté définitif mais celle
là restera et elle restera comme un lieu
il est un peu lourd le lieu ce que c'est
un lieu de prison oui c'est un lieu
normalement d'apparat qui va être
transformée après le départ des rois de
france
en lieu de détention tout d'abord pour
des prisonniers de guerre on a quelques
témoignages d'espagnol et de portugais
et même de suisse
détenus ici et puis jusqu'à là au milieu
du xxème siècle puisqu'en dans l'épisode
de la dernière guerre des tirailleurs
sénégalais seront détenus très
temporairement au moment de l'occupation
voilà et certains d'entre eux ont marqué
comme on peut le voir la sueur sur les
murs certains d'entre eux ont marqué
dans des espoirs et leurs rêves et leurs
espoirs en même temps voilà tout à fait
on a les célèbres bars les sépare des
prisonniers sas universel mais certains
ont voulu personnaliser leur passage et
c'est la trace à l'exemple d'un suisse
qui a été fait prisonnier à bruxelles
l'essentiel des dates qui figure sur ses
murs elle correspond pas aux principaux
conflits menés par la france en europe
ou au xviie siècle et xviiie siècles
voilà et c'est un endroit sûr le sur
lequel on veut faire de grandes études
sur le graphe en général exactement il
suffit d'une pointe de charbon ou d'un
ongle pour ainsi laisser sa trace dans
l'histoire non merci marque était de
nous avoir fait découvrir cet endroit à
la fois magique et à la fois un peu
obscur voilà hatubou fourier nous sommes
ici dans la salle du conseil
ce qu'il faudrait dire sur françois 1er
ce qui a été dit dans le reportage c'est
que c'est un enfant françois 1er qui vit
dans les travaux oui tout à fait il a
passé toute son enfance à au château
d'amboise dans un chantier gigantesque
c'est un des plus gros chantiers royaux
de l'époque au milieu des maçons des
ouvriers des six qui valide le goût de
cette de l'architecturé y sentiez puis
les choses changer car en laissant
arrive on peut on peut l'imaginer et oui
dans cette ambiance de travaux qu'il est
qu'il ait pris le virus de
l'architecturé doit pendant son enfance
dont il a eu le virus de l'humanisme
aussi des sciences et de beaucoup de
choses
il a la rencontre avec nanard de vinci
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
vous le spécialiste sur léonard de vinci
vous préférez l'artiste ou le
scientifique le fabricant machine le
concepteur de machines
je crois que je préfère peut-être que
philosophe le philosophe voilà et bien
ça c'est une excellence des puces merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
eh bien on va vous proposer une des
inventions de léonard de vinci ou
parachute il vous plaît si felix
baumgartner a sauté depuis l'espace et à
atterrir en toute sécurité
c'est grâce à léona raccourci certes
mais de vinci a tout de même inventé le
premier parachute de l'histoire ce
parachute il le décide le décrit dans le
codex atlantique eut 114 180 moulineaux
si un homme à poigne de tonnes dont
toutes les ouvertures ont été bouclés et
qui mesure 12 brasse de largeur sur 12
de profondeur celui ci pourra se doter
de n'importe quelle altitude 100 de
m'acheter
d'où brasse milanaise ça équivaut
environ à 7 mètres sa forme quand même
une très grande tante pyramidale seul
détail que léonard de vinci semble avoir
oublié harnais de sécurité selon lui
le passager est suspendu les bras levés
et se tient fermement à des cordes fixé
au châssis
c'est tout de même pas très pratique
trop lourd forme trophos beaucoup
d'experts doutent et de son bon
fonctionnement
jusqu'en 2001 lorsqu'adriano nicholas
construite est le design de l'ingénieur
et cela fonctionne léonard de vinci
confirme son statut du chili voilà pour
le parachute de leurs biens si regardez
comme c'est beau c'est magnifique on se
retrouve au bord de la loire le fleuve
royal c'est beau un château d'amboise
vous en aurez plein de rendez vous comme
ça jusqu'à fin juin bien entendu puisque
la semaine prochaine on sera à bord des
petits rendez vous pour le week-end
en indre et loire à saint-antoine du
rocher l'espace nobuyoshi ixelles a
consacré justement et des artistes
contemporains
et bien tout simplement à à léonard de
vinci avec des clins d'oeil à ses
formidables je change de fiches en début
mai à la pagode de chanteloup léonard de
vinci précurseur de la vision
tridimensionnelle ou m'en direz tant
et puis on va terminer avec une autre
exposition au château du rivau c'est
pareil c'est en indre et loire
c'est un joli petit clin d'oeil qui a
été fait à léonard de vinci avec des
artistes c'est tout à fait étonnant à
les y voilà pour notre agenda lui si je
vais vous dire une chose c'est simple on
va se retrouver dès vendredi prochain va
se retrouver à blois je vous donne aussi
rendez vous lundi soir parce qu'il ya
une autre émission donc le débat du dock
consacré bien entendu la renaissance
avec l'excellent film les codes de
chambord et puis je sais que vous ferez
partie de l'équipe alors on aimerait
vous le rendez vous très bientôt et
j'espère vous faire tout savoir tout
connaître j'espère sur la renaissance
bonne soirée à vous